another patient is discharged from a
hospital in a noite province in eastern
China for the first time China's
government says the number of patients
cured of the new corona virus surpasses
the total being treated Changhua 52.1%
of all coronavirus cases have been cured
this signals a good trend nationally
millions of workers are returning to
work to get the world's second biggest
economy moving again but a travel
lockdown remains in Hubei Province the
epicenter of the crisis around 37,000
there are sick 7,000 of them seriously
ill at least 25 medics have died of the
virus more than 70 countries and
territories have imposed travel
restrictions on South Korea where around
3700 people aren't affected in the
hardest hit city of daegu hospital beds
are in short supply an increasing number
of cases are linked to the shin chon GE
religious sect Health Service
administrators are investigating the
branch of the church based in the
Chinese city of Wuhan the size of the
group is not that big but there are some
cases where we believe people visited
Wuhan in January in Japan baseball teams
played to empty stadiums many sports
gatherings have been postponed or
canceled raising fears that the
coronavirus could derail the Tokyo
Olympics due to start in July around 900
cases have been confirmed in Japan most
from the Diamond Princess cruise ship
with coronavirus cases around the world
steadily rising Chinese leaders are
turning their attention to threats from
abroad China's government hasn't yet
imposed travel restrictions on any
country but officials say they're ready
to repatriate Chinese citizens from any
affected by the outbreak if necessary
Katrina Yoon al Jazeera Beijing